Are you or is someone you love suffering from mommy brain?
I used to be able to remember entire to-do lists in my head.
Now it's enough if I can enter a room without forgetting what I came in for.
I love being a parent but I'm exhausted.
And I forgot what I was gonna say.
Mommy brain is a common condition in new parents,...
...caused largely by restless nights and interrupted sleep.
Talk to your favorite new parent about Mimo, the smart baby monitor.
Mimo's machine washable onesies monitor the respiration,...
...skin temperature, body position and activity level of infants.
The information is sent directly to your smartphone in real time.
You can also listen to audio and you can set notifications for any changes.
Mimo can also track your baby's sleeping, feeding and other schedules over time.
Easy to set up, safe for baby and allows parents to rest easy.